[Música]
pensáis que los datos pueden salvar la
vida de personas
la inteligencia artificial hubiera
salvado a mi abuela
hace 10 años una mañana nos despertamos
y ambos incapaces de levantar a mi
abuela estaba como profundamente dormida
por mucho que le agita vamos no
conseguíamos que abriera los ojos
y mi abuela era diabética la insulina es
una molécula que regula el azúcar dentro
de su cuerpo no funcionaba en ella igual
que en todos vosotros
esta mañana mi abuela estaba sufriendo
un coma diabético estaba producido por
una hipoglucemia
esto quiere decir que mi abuela tenía su
cerebro en standby porque no había
suficiente azúcar que llegaba a él
hace tres años una noche de campamento
que parecía aparentemente normal la
inteligencia artificial hizo que fuera
una noche totalmente normal
yo era monitora de un chico que era
diabético en su caso la insulina ni
siquiera se producía dentro de su cuerpo
esa noche fuimos a hacerle una medición
en el sensor que este chico tenía en el
brazo
y gracias a que este sensor tenía
inteligencia artificial pudimos saber
que si no actuamos rápido este chico iba
a correr la misma suerte que mi abuela
la diferencia entre estas dos historias
son siete años siete años en los que
hemos implementado modelos de
inteligencia artificial dentro de la
medicina
pero en este punto seguramente os
estaréis preguntando qué es eso de
inteligencia artificial que marina no
deja de repetir pues bien la
inteligencia artificial no es nada no es
un ente enorme ya como una información y
un día nos va a controlar a todos y la
inteligencia artificial tampoco
significa que el día de mañana cuando
vayamos a un hospital nos encontraremos
a robots en lugar de a personal
sanitario
realmente la inteligencia artificial es
la unión de dos cosas aparentemente
aburridas es la unión de la informática
y la estadística
gracias a la capacidad de computación
que tenemos hoy en día vemos maximizadas
las aplicaciones clásicas que tienen la
estadística
existen muchos tipos de inteligencia
artificial y hoy os voy a hablar de uno
del machine learning que son las
máquinas que aprenden
os preguntaréis cómo funciona cómo
hacemos que una máquina aprenda que sea
inteligente pues bien para entenderlo
quiero que os imaginéis a un pequeño
dónde cillo a nuestro dende cillo le
habíamos dado información sobre el
tiempo meteorológico por ejemplo le
vamos a dar los registros de los últimos
10 años le vamos a decir cuál es la
temperatura cual es la humedad en el
ambiente la velocidad del viento el tipo
de nubes que en el cielo y también
incluiremos en esta tabla de información
una columna que nos indique si ese día
finalmente llovió o no llovió
de esta forma nuestro duendecillo tomará
toda esa información y la memorizar
hasta que sea capaz de sacar sus propias
conclusiones
después a nuestro dembélé volveremos a
presentar el mismo tipo de información y
será él quien nos diga si finalmente
lloverá o no lloverá
imaginaros que en lugar de darle
información sobre el tiempo atmosférico
le damos información sobre pacientes con
diabetes
le podemos decir cuál es el nivel de
glucosa de nuestro paciente antes de
comer la comida que va a comer y así
nuestro modelo podrá predecir cuál será
el nivel de glucosa en los próximos 15
20 o hasta una hora más tarde
si le damos más información al modelo
como por ejemplo la actividad física que
va a realizar nuestro paciente podemos
conseguir una predicción más acertada
todos sabemos que no es lo mismo
comernos una manzana y quedarnos así
sentados que comernos una manzana y
salir a correr
con toda esta información podemos lograr
una predicción que le ayuda a nuestro
paciente a elegir mucho mejor la
cantidad de insulina que ha de
inyectarse en su cuerpo en ese momento
exacto del día
hemos creado modelos de inteligencia
artificial y machine learning que son
capaces de diagnosticar pacientes a los
que no se ven sus síntomas
hay un modelo en particular que está
entrenado con datos de la voz escucha a
las personas
este modelo busca diagnosticar a
pacientes de parkinson en estadios muy
tempranos a los que ni siquiera se les
ve temblar que es el síntoma más
característico de esta enfermedad
como muchos sabréis el parkinson es una
enfermedad que afecta a nuestros
músculos
y nuestras cuerdas vocales son un
músculo
entonces nuestro modelo será capaz de
detectar una especie de onda muy
característica que le ayude a detectar
si ese paciente tiene parkinson o no lo
tiene
hemos conseguido también darle a los
ordenadores la capacidad de ver con ojos
de médicos hemos creado modelos
entrenados con radiografías que son
capaces de detectar si dentro de esas
radiografías se detecta un tumor
también hemos hecho modelos un poquito
más avanzados que son capaces de
decirnos qué mutación en específico
tiene este tumor
cuando hasta ahora este proceso se
llevaba a cabo en un laboratorio tomando
una biopsia del tumor del paciente y
secuenciando su adn para determinar la
mutación
para crear todos estos modelos
necesitamos una infinidad de datos
os imaginaréis que los científicos de
datos que los crearon tuvieron acceso a
una base de datos como muchísimas
radiografías por ejemplo para nuestro
modelo anti tumores pero nada más lejos
de la realidad
estos científicos de datos sólo pudieron
acceder a unas pocas radiografías que
les dio el médico en particular con el
que estaban haciendo este estudio
si tenemos pocos datos es muy probable
que nuestros datos estén sesgados
si nuestros datos están sesgados y no
nos aportan suficiente información es
muy probable que el modelo que creemos a
partir de ellos en un futuro sea inútil
e incapaz de generalizar y dar respuesta
a la pregunta por el que está creado
si queremos que podamos incluir el
machine learning dentro de la medicina
necesitamos sacar los datos de las
cárceles en los que están encerrados
necesitamos liberar los datos hacerlos
disponibles para todos y esto tiene un
nombre
el lugar donde se encontrarán esos datos
es un data lake un lago de datos quiero
que os imaginéis un gran lago lleno de
agua con diferentes ríos que van
dejándola en este lago
yo me lo imagino así pero vosotros os lo
podéis imaginar como queráis
los diferentes ríos de información que
llegarán a este lago son el historial
clínico que llevamos recogiendo a lo
largo de toda nuestra vida las
radiografías de las que hablaba antes o
incluso aquella analítica que nos
hicimos hace años y casi ni nos
acordamos de ella pues que también
podemos incluir en nuestro lago de datos
los pasos que damos al día las
pulsaciones que recoge nuestro relojito
o incluso cómo suena nuestra voz cuando
hablamos por teléfono
no necesitamos añadir ningún sensor más
ni inventar lo tenemos mucha información
ya disponible
con todo esto en nuestro data lake
podemos crear un modelo de machine
learning que sea capaz de avisar a
nuestro médico si encuentra algún cambio
en nuestro cuerpo que sea relevante
así el médico podrá llamar nuestra
consulta y asesorarnos mejor sobre qué
está sucediendo dentro de nosotros
pero es que no solo sería beneficioso a
nivel de paciente sino que también sería
muy beneficioso a nivel sociedad los
ensayos clínicos por ejemplo que hemos
escuchado mucho hablar gracias a la
vacuna del cob y estos ensayos saldrán
de los hospitales a la calle
la selección de pacientes por ejemplo
que es una de las partes más complicadas
de estos procesos será mucho más
sencilla porque hoy lo que hacemos es
decir hospital para hospital preguntando
por los pacientes que tengan las
características adecuadas para nuestro
estudio pero con nuestro data lake
podemos encontrar todos esos pacientes a
golpe de click
además seremos capaces de determinar si
un medicamento no está funcionando por
el propio medicamento o por si el
paciente está expuesto a unas
condiciones tan de bien tales que ahora
sí conocemos que están haciendo que ese
medicamento no funcione como se esperaba
quiero que os imaginéis también como
hubiera sido marzo de 2020 si hubiésemos
tenido disponible un data lake
muy probablemente hubiéramos encontrado
un patrón en la sintomatología de los
pacientes con kobe
haber encontrado ese patrón nos hubiera
evitado colapsar las urgencias y más
tarde las ucis perdón
la historia también cambiaría muchísimo
si ahora con las vacunas tuviéramos
también acceso al data lic
si estas vacunas llevarán el tan
comentado chip del que hablaban los
negacionistas que por favor que nadie
salga de aquí pensando que existe ese
chip porque es mentira no existe pero
bueno si existiera ese chip y estuviese
conectado a nuestro data lake es
probable que a día de hoy no siguiéramos
descubriendo efectos secundarios sobre
las vacunas hubiéramos tenido la
información disponible desde el
principio porque estaría ya en nuestro
data lake
al final almacenar información es un
concepto muy antiguo todos conocemos la
biblioteca de alejandría
pero si almacenamos y analizamos la
información que nos aporta valor podemos
cambiar radicalmente la manera en que
hacemos soy medicina
con nuestro data lake podemos hacer que
la medicina pase de ser una ciencia que
cura a personas a ser una ciencia que
previene que las personas caigan
enfermas
podemos hacer además que si caen
enfermas el tratamiento será mucho más
personalizado porque tendremos
información disponible sobre el cuerpo
de nuestros pacientes que hoy no
conocemos
con este data lake nuestro sistema
sanitario de salud dejará de ser uno de
los sistemas mejores del mundo y pasará
a ser el sistema sanitario más
inteligente del mundo
una mañana quiero ser capaz de
levantarme y no solo ver qué tiempo va a
hacer en mi móvil quiero levantarme y
saber que mi cuerpo está bien
que el cuerpo de la gente que me importa
está bien
mi sueño es levantarme con la certeza de
que mi madre no va a correr la misma
suerte que mi abuela
mi madre también es diabética y le puede
pasar lo mismo
afortunadamente mi sueño cada día está
más cerca de ser una realidad muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]